MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
to Talks at Google
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
This morning, I'm excited
to introduce Nick Montfort,
Associate Professor
of Digital Media
at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
There, he directs The
Trope Tank research lab,
studying literary generators
and computational art.
For over a decade, he served
on the board of the Electronic
Literature Organization and he's
principal of the naming firm
Nomnym.
Today, Nick will read from
his latest book, "#!." "#!"
presents computer
generated poems alongside
their corresponding source code.
His other works include
"Twisty Little Passages",
a survey of interactive
fiction, and "10 PRINT",
a 10-author collaboration
on create computing.
Please welcome Nick Montfort.
NICK MONTFORT: Thanks.
Thanks very much.
"Form intends intense
verse crease to tense form
tense vent verse tone
verse form crease form
vent tends to crease to tends
form form vent form crease tone
verse tense.
Crease vent vent
tends inverse tone
into verse form
verse verse form tone
tense in tense vent
crease verse tone
tends verse tends tends tense
verse crease form tone vent
into tends to crease vent to
crease vent verse verse vent
to crease vent form tends vent
crease tense form tends crease
in intone.
To tone verse vent
crease intends
vent vent to tense in form
crease vent crease form
to to tends tone verse
form vent tends tends to."
The work I have been
reading, "Round",
is a very simple
program and poem
that's available on the web
at round.newbinarypress.com
and, as with all my
creative digital work, also
available on my site, nickm.com.
It displays the digits of pi.
But instead of using the
numerals 0 through 9,
the program presents
strings of text
that correspond to each digit.
Eight of them are words
that can stand alone,
one is the prefix "in-",
and one is a line break,
which shapes the poem into
lines of irregular length.
So since 3 is
represented by "form,"
1 by "in," 4 by "tends," 1
by "in," 5 by "tense," and 9
by "verse," the first digits
of pi-- 3, 1, 4, 1, 5,
9-- are represented by "form
intends intense verse."
"Round" is a
computational poem that
is both non-interactive
and deterministic.
It is computational
in that computation
is an essential
aspect of the work,
non-interactive because
there's no input accepted
as the program runs,
and deterministic
because the text produced
should be the same, each time,
on any properly
functioning computer.
The poem is also
infinite, or boundless.
There's no final
line or internally
specified condition that
will cause it to stop.
"Round" does not contain
any list of digits of pi.
It computes each digit
using a spigot algorithm.
If it did store, as data,
1,000 digits, or 10,000,
or any finite
number, the program
would be unable to continue
representing the digits of pi
after that point.
Instead, "Round" computes pi.
As the program runs,
the production of text
slows down as more
and more steps
are necessary to
determine the next digit.
You may be able to see that
in this Python instance
of the program.
The multitasking computer
running the program
will also begin to run
other processes more slowly
and will physically heat up.
The computer's fan will work
harder as the processor labors
to complete these computations.
"Verse tense tense tense
vent crease crease form
intone crease tense form tense
verse tends vent increase
vent tends vent in in intone
tends tense crease vent tends
in crease tone inverse
form vent tense crease
in in tense tense
tense verse to tends
tends to crease
crease verse tends
vent verse tense
tends verse form."
Of course, this is
probably the audience
I need to tell least about
the materiality of computing,
the labor that might be
involved in scanning in books,
the physical and material
computation that's
required to do large amounts
of symbol manipulation, data
retrieval, and delivery.
But this is a way
of looking at this
and, for people whose
experience of computing
is maybe more ethereal,
and for people
who believe that digital
poetry and the work that we
do with text on the computer
is actually immaterial,
this is something of an answer
to that showing that there
is something going on in terms
of computation, something
almost mechanical, that
is a laborious process.
And it also questions
various ideas
of the need to combine things
at random-- in a digital poem,
for instance-- which is not
literally done in this case.
Although, obviously, it's a
quite unpredictable sequence
unless you know that
it's the digits of pi
that are being represented.
So I wrote this next
poem, "Taroko Gorge,"
in January, 2009,
in about one day
at Taiwan's Taroko
Gorge National Park.
It's actually a pretty
conventional poem
compared to a lot of
the things that I right,
or a lot of the things
that my programs output.
It's meant to be a
generator of nature poetry.
I figure that if
other people had
gone to beautiful,
natural places-- as,
stereotypically, is
the case-- and they've
written poems about
them, why couldn't I
go to a beautiful, natural
place and write a poetry
generator about this place.
This one, also, is
a boundless poem,
running until it's interrupted.
But as I think you can
see, it's not formless.
Each of the longer
strophes begins and ends
with a path line of a certain
type representing motion
along a path in
Taroko Gorge Park.
And in between, there are
zero or more view lines,
representing stopping to look
at the scenery at a designated
viewing spot.
And then, these
individual lines that
appear in between
the longer strophes
are what I call cave lines,
representing the tunnels
that Chiang Kai-Shek had
his nationalist army carve
through the mountains
when they came to Taiwan.
"Stones pace the ripplings.
Shapes sweep the flows.
Translate the objective driven.
Layer paces the coves.
Coves hold.
Mists trail the stones.
Shade the encompassing rough.
Brow ranges the flows.
The crags hold.
Shapes rest.
Layer ranges the stone.
Shade the encompassing,
rough, sinuous straight."
Now I was pleased
to do this exercise
and to undertake this
nature poetry generator.
One of the things that
you see in the book
is that, as with all of the
outputs of these systems,
they're presented after the
code for the program itself.
This is, in part,
just a reference back
to the days of
basic programming,
in the '70s and '80s, where one
would find books and magazines
that presented to code
for people to type in.
They gave some sample output
so you could make sure
that what you were
inputting was really
what it was supposed to be.
And they gave an attitude of
openness toward computing.
And of course, on
the web, you can just
view source and
examine how things
are done in JavaScript
in the same way.
This is what Scott Rettberg,
a friend and collaborator
of mine, did.
And without telling
me about it, he also
made his own work out
of "Taroko Gorge"--
a piece called "Tokyo Garage."
And where I wrote a poem about
a beautiful natural place
that I'd actually
visited myself,
what Scott did was to write
a poem about an urban place
in the East that he
had never been to,
supplied only by his
feverish imagination
of what it would be like
to be in Tokyo and all
the stereotypes that
we have in the West.
"Translator funds the libation.
Dealers reverse.
Protagonist suffers
the libation.
Indoor the electrical,
banal blinking.
Teenager confuses the kids.
Earthquakes reverse.
Talk show host orients
the sushi joints.
Harmonize the abbreviated."
Well, suffice it to say that
other people started doing this
as well.
J.R. Carpenter created
this piece, "Gorge"--
a modified version
of "Taroko Gorge"--
which describes another
endless process,
that of gluttony and
endless consumption,
and the disgusting and yet
unstoppable processes thereof.
And J.R. did some
additional pieces.
One of these that I
certainly want to point out
is Andrew Plotkins's
piece, in which
he took all the remixes that
happened up to this point,
showed them remixed
with themselves
and with other remixes, and
also displayed the code that
corresponded to what was being
printed at different times.
So this is really
a tour de force.
And he doesn't actually--
only a small amount
of my original code,
obviously, is part of this.
It's a different
type of take off.
This is a remix of Eric
Snodgrass's "Yoko Engorged,"
which is about Yoko Ono
and her performance art.
And this is a remix of "Fred
& George" and "Toy Garbage"
down here.
And then, some people
simply created work
that-- many people use the
particular form that I created,
of these path lines, view
lines, and cave lines.
But some people
actually discarded that.
They just sort of took the
code as a starting point
for making their own sort of
project with their own form.
And Sonny Rae Tempest did
that, creating these quatrains
in his piece, "Camel Tail",
that are a patchwork of all
of the lyrics from Metallica's
nine major studio albums.
You can see here,
the production is
something of quite
a different sort.
But I think it rhetorically
gets across the point
that metal is more of a texture
than a narrative or a story,
right.
It's that you can
take these lines
and put them together at random,
and you still sort of feel
what you're supposed
to feel when
you're listening to the song.
"Much too young to focus.
No more!
Anger.
Master."
Pretty much, that
could be a lyric.
All right.
So to end this most coherent
section of my reading,
I'll present some of the output
from my first Ruby program.
I was commissioned
to write something
for the book, "The
Ill-Tempered Rubyist," which
is sort of code poems.
And it had this title.
And I thought, well,
I'll need to see
what I can do,
actually, in Ruby.
So the program is
built with text
from Edward
Fitzgerald's translation
of "The Rubaiyat
of Omar Khayyam."
And before I read
the output, I'll
read you the program itself,
not enunciating the punctuation
marks well enough for
you to type it in.
But you can see
the book for that.
And I think you'll get some
sense of what animates it,
even if you aren't particularly
familiar with Ruby,
as, in fact, I'm not.
"Rubaiyat.
Shebang, user, bin, Ruby.
A phrases equal oriate,
alternate, along with,
argument, another,
absolute, alchemist,
arrest the, an empty, a Ruby,
a little, a thousand, a book
of, and peace to, a jug
of, a loaf of, a distant,
and out of, and lose your, a
moments, amid the, are all but,
awoke from, and by the, all
this of, a shallow, as much as,
as brings the.
B phrases equal beneath
the, before the,
but still the, beside
the, beloved, better
be, by logic, blaspheme
the, before us, beset the.
Rhymes equal stare, there, care,
dare, snare, bear, air, hair,
tear, ne'er.
Non-rhymes equal sun, stars,
shaft, cup, bird, wing, winds,
dust, not, lamp, lip,
dusk, balm, bowl, song.
Six times endings equal
rhymes dot sample three.
Endings dot insert two
non-rhymes dot sample.
Beginnings equal A
phrases dot sample three.
Beginnings dot insert
two B phrases dot sample.
Zero up to three.
I puts beginning I plus
base plus endings I. Puts.
A little bare are all but there.
By logic shaft, an empty stare.
Absolute there amid the stair.
Blaspheme the dusk,
argument bare.
And by the there, an empty air.
Better be cup.
A distant hair.
A thousand stare.
A moment's care.
Beloved cup, arrest the snare.
Awoke from tear a jug of ne'er.
Better be cup.
A distant stare.
A thousand tear.
A jug of snare.
Beset the balm.
A moment's air."
And I'll read you the version
that is printed in the book.
"Amid the care
and lose your air.
Better be wing.
Another there.
A distant care.
A loaf of ne'er.
By logic dust and by the dare.
A Ruby there.
An empty air.
Blaspheme the cup
and out of hair.
And use your bare.
Absolute dare.
Before us wing.
Argument care.
As springs the
care amid the care,
before us stars another snare.
Along with tear
and piece to dare.
Beside the cup, argument care."
Now in the book, you can
see a few conceptual poems
that refer to some
earlier digital work.
One that is pretty
simple in form
is based on the permutation
poems of Brion Gysin, which
Ian Sommerville implemented
computationally.
And so "I am that
I am" is a sort
of homage to that,
that simply displays
all the permutations of
the five full vowels.
And there's also a piece based
on a work of Claude Closky,
which is the first m numbers
in alphabetical order.
So Claude Closky did
a piece, in 1989,
both in English and
in French, where
he presented the first thousand
numbers in alphabetical order.
And of course, they're
alphabetized differently
in French and English
when they're spelled out.
And so he showed these.
And to me, it was a
very interesting display
of the arbitrariness of our
various systems of language
when it comes up against number.
So I did a version
called "The First M
Numbers in Alphabetical Order."
And it generates
and alphabetizes
the first thousand
Roman numerals.
So I'll show you a little
of the Concrete Perl
series of programs.
There was one of
these, actually,
that I showed early on,
before I got started.
And that was
"Letterformed Terrain."
And this is a piece that uses
a Perl special variable that
has a value equal to 60.
We actually did a-- I worked
with a Russian translator
and we did a
transliteration to Cyrillic
of this piece,
"Letterformed Terrain."
And we had a Russian
title for it.
And for one thing, the
landscape is denser,
because there's more characters
in the Cyrillic alphabet.
But that value of
60 stays the same.
So one of the possibilities,
even at the letter level,
for moving between
languages and alphabets,
is to see how it is that
the systems we use--
Perl ASCII, Unicode-- come
up against different human
languages, and how
they work differently.
I'll just show you the code for
that, itself, which is that.
This is a 32 character
Perl program.
And I have a set of these.
Concrete Perl programs are
all 32 characters long.
And then, what I'll
show after, I'll
show a few examples
of ppg256-- 256
that series of 256
character Perl programs.
I showed some of these to an
actual, professional, Perl
programmer-- not
someone silly, like me,
who's playing around with Perl
to do these sorts of things.
And I showed, actually,
one of the ppg256 systems.
And this person was
completely unimpressed by what
the program did.
But he looked at the
program and said, "Redo?"
Because he'd actually never
heard of that keyword.
But it turns out that
the most-- as far
as I can tell-- the most
concise way to create a loop
is to have a code block with
"redo" at the end, in Perl.
So look at that.
Even I can learn
something about Perl
which probably
shouldn't be learned.
So let me ask if we can
make, maybe, the screen-- we
can do, for the video,
full screen for this.
And I'll show you
"Alphabet Expanding."
So I find this mesmerizing.
It's not at all a
piece of video art.
You have to start it or have
someone start it for you,
I think, to really
get the effect of it.
And of course, it helps
to know the code that's
animating it as well.
These programs-- these
Concrete Perl programs--
are written for terminals
or consoles of any geometry.
So they're meant to work
no matter what typography
and what size of window
or console you're using.
This one, here, is simply
increasing the amount
of spaces between the alphabet,
which it's printing repeatedly.
And it's doing that
very, very slowly.
And so that alphabet
goes in and out
of phase with the
size of the terminal,
producing these different
types of effects.
So another one of
these is "All the Names
of God," which is printing every
one letter, and then, every two
letter, and then, every
three letter word,
and so on, until
eventually-- because it's
trying to pre-compute them
all in memory-- it will crash.
And if you've read Arthur C.
Clarke's "The Nine Billion
Names of God," you'll probably
be glad that it does crash,
since you know what the
outcome might be of continuing.
And the last one of these is
actually a fairly simple one,
but one that, I
think, has a point.
It's called "ASCII Hegemony."
So when we translated
this to Russian
or transliterated
it to Cyrillic,
this one stayed the same.
Because this is just all the
printable characters in ASCII.
And actually, early electronic
literature work in Russian
was done in ASCII.
Because there was not support
for the Cyrillic alphabet
on the first computers that
were popularly available there.
And even as we continue with
amazing projects like Unicode,
there's still these questions
of how different programming
languages and
different environments
support different alphabets.
So you can get Latin alphabet
in Perl by saying A dot dot Z.
But you can't do that
for Greek, or Cyrillic,
or other alphabets.
Of course, you can
work around that.
But your program
isn't going to end up
being 32 characters
long in those cases.
So I'll finish up-- this
next section, the reading,
there's probably two
more little pieces here.
But I'll finish up
by reading just a few
of the ppg256 pieces.
Let me show you what
these look like.
So here's the first of
these, for instance.
Besides the comments
here, I made this file
so that it could
be run on Windows.
But the program itself is just
the bottom three lines there.
And it doesn't use-- as with
Concrete Perl, of course--
it doesn't use any
external stores of data.
It doesn't do anything online.
Everything that it
produces is actually
encoded in that 256
character program.
Of course, it uses the
Perl programming language,
and all the capabilities
that that has,
and all the ways that
that animates computation.
But everything has to be
packed into that short program.
And so for me,
this is a challenge
to try to explore things
about Perl, and also,
about poetry and language.
How could I make a
very concise program
that would at least look like
a poetry generator-- would
be read that way
by someone who was
a generous, willing
viewer of the program?
And so this is what
I came up with.
I'll tell a little bit about
this before I read from it.
So the first task
I set myself was
to generate a very,
very large vocabulary--
how could I create a
large number of words?
Well, there's well
known ways to do this.
So in Claude Shannon's
"Mathematical Theory
of Communication," from 1948, he
describes the process by which,
through using conditional
probabilities and increasing n,
one might be able to
generate text at random,
including words at random.
The problem with
this is that if you
want to use even just
bigram probabilities,
you have 26 letters.
And then, there's 26 letters
that could come after it.
That's 276 letters.
And so that's going to be a lot
of conditional probabilities
for 256 characters of code.
They're probably not
going to fit in there
very easily, if at all.
So I was trying to figure out
a different way to do this.
And the way I came up with
was-- I tried a bunch of things.
And I was getting,
maybe, dictionary words
like 3% of the time.
It was very futile.
And then I decided, OK,
well, what if I just
take the first two letters
of common four-letter words
and the last two letters of
common four-letter words?
And I'll just jam them together
at random and see what happens.
Well, as it happened,
even without any fix up,
I was getting 60% dictionary
words by doing that.
It was pretty amazing.
I had a chance to speak to a
phonologist at MIT about this,
and to describe this process.
And he said, oh yeah, turns
out, from monosyllables,
the initial and
final bigrams are
going to be pretty
much independent.
And so my first thought was,
oh well, he knew that already.
That's too bad.
And then, I was like,
well, he probably
went to graduate school for
like seven years to learn that.
And I was just playing
around with a Perl program
for a few hours.
So maybe that's interesting.
And there's other things that
I learned about this as well.
So if you just produce
a string of words,
it's not that recognizable
as a poem to most people.
But if you shape them
into lines and stanzas,
ah, it's starting to
look more like a poem.
And then, I spent a good
deal of those 256 characters
producing these titles at
the top of each of these,
just indenting by one space.
And so it turns out that
makes things, at least to me,
look considerably
more like a poem.
These framing elements and
the overall shape of the poem
are quite important to it.
"The car.
Tat to baed.
The bure.
Hoke no tosh.
Toes on hoes.
Cack on bar.
The pang.
Rall on mosh.
Bat of dear."
So I'll show you the
second one of these.
I tried to do some things
quite differently here.
I was satisfied with
a small vocabulary.
There's only 89
words this generates,
including all the close
clasp words, the ampersand.
But I wanted to have a
variable line length.
I wanted to have a
shape of a stanza.
In fact, the line tends
to become smaller,
as you can see, in the pans
here, as this continues.
And I wanted to have variability
of word length as well.
And I was willing to sacrifice
that large vocabulary
to do this.
So I get things like
this in this poem.
"The kits.
The pan-- a kin.
A twin.
Of twit twits fit.
Shill.
Span-- the skill.
Sit & skit.
To chin-- a shin.
A spill.
To sit.
Fan.
The grin.
Grit.
The grins.
Twin & shill.
Of spit.
Chill shills the grin.
Spin.
To spill.
A kit.
Chill.
Twill."
A solution to generating
the indefinite article
is to not produce any words
that begin with vowels
or that begin with vowel sounds.
So I never have to produce "an."
I only have to produce "a."
So there's a lot of things like
that, which are not, certainly,
general purpose
solutions, but which
given interesting-- for me--
an interesting engagement
with language and understanding
of their possible textures.
So there's actually
seven of these.
But I'll read a
bit from the third.
And then, I'll move
on to this final thing
that I wanted to share with you.
And this third one, I decided,
I'll get rid of the titles.
And I'll try to look
at compound words--
how can I compound a list
of three-letter words
that standalone as
words into new words?
And how can I make something
that seems like, maybe,
the beginning of a narrative--
not a full story, but something
that suggests a
situation, something
that's suggesting narrativity?
And this is what I came up with.
"One_red_manape and
the_wax_apeape cut_on.
_hip_godbot and
the__boyeel ran_off.
The_wan_manhat and
__apeboy put_out.
One_botelf and
on__elfnun jam_her.
One__godman and
one_red_elforc set_on.
The__nunman and
one_fat_orcbot hit_us.
One_red_hatorc and
the__apeboy put_her."
So that's ppg256 3.
And it's the third of seven
of these very concise Perl
programs which-- I think
you get the sense-- I'm not
trying to use to express things
about my life or emotion,
but I'm trying to use to explore
language in a poetic way,
through the making
of a poetry generator
and the making of a poetic
language-- in some ways,
the same type of investigation
that people are doing when
they're doing linguistics or
computational linguistics,
but through a different,
non-scientific means--
that is, this poetic production.
So I wanted to share with
you a book that I just
finished and just had printed.
It's called "Megawatt."
And it's a book that--
there's some story behind it.
The seventh of these
ppg256 programs
is based on a passage from
Samuel Beckett's second novel,
"Watt."
And after doing this, I made
a Demoscene production called
"Nanowatt," which is a 3.5K
VIC-20 program that generates
8K of "Watt"
exactly, in English.
And then, it goes on to
generate 8K of "Watt" in French.
And these are certainly out
of the ordinary endeavors.
But the point of engaging
with the novel in this way
is to try to read it,
to try to understand it
through reimplementing it.
So I'll show a little
bit of-- here's the--
So this is the book cover.
And this is a little
from the preface,
which is also the doc string.
And "Megawatt," then, is the
third computational project
I've undertaken to try to deal
with Samuel Beckett's novel.
This novel has some more or
less ordinary language in it.
But it also has these
really bizarre passages
in which every combination
of three or four
different elements
will be described.
So it will be
described, for instance,
that Watt heard voices which
sometimes sang, cried, stated,
or murmured or that he felt
calm, and free, and glad,
but maybe not calm,
and free, glad,
but at least calm and free,
or free and glad, and so on.
And so what I've done is to
re-implement these passages
from "Watt" computationally--
created programs
that would write
what Beckett wrote.
And then, I extended them so
that they would say even more.
So the 2 and 1/2 pages
that are in "Watt"
describing Mr. Knott's
physical appearance occupy,
here, more than-- the
corresponding section
in "Megawatt" occupies
more than 200 pages.
And I'll read you a
little bit of that.
"With regard to the so
important matter of Mr. Knott's
physical appearance,
Watt had, unfortunately,
little or nothing to say.
For one day, Mr. Knott would
be thin, small, pale, dark,
brown-eyed, ectomorphic,
clean-shaven, and erect,
and the next, thin, small, pale,
dark, brown-eyed, ectomorphic,
clean-shaven, and stooped, and
the next, thin, small, pale,
dark, brown-eyed, ectomorphic,
clean-shaven, and leaning,
and the next, thin, small, pale,
dark, brown-eyed, ectomorphic,
bearded, and erect."
OK.
And so on, for more
than 200 pages.
And at the end of
this book is all
of the code that's
used to generate
the main text of the book.
It's a 350-line Python program.
And from a standpoint of reading
from literary experience,
it seems that we're
confronted with things
that, although in terms
of the amount of time
it takes to read
them, we physically
have the time, in our lives,
to read something like this.
But it's illegible due to not
being created in a human way,
for reading.
But we can still encounter
it computationally.
And so "Megawatt" is
part of that project.
And "#!" is another aspect of
that project, not to confuse,
not to puzzle people, but
to show that computation is
something that can engage with
poetry and language in new
sorts of ways.
And of course, the focus is
on these very simple programs,
which, for the most part,
can be used offline.
There's only one
part of "Megawatt"
that even makes use of WordNet.
Because there's the
dish that Mr. Knott eats
that seems to contain
every possible food in it.
And so I use WordNet to
enumerate that possibility.
So that's some about
the project of "#!"
and this newly released book.
And with that, I'll
open it up to questions.
AUDIENCE: So does your
code come with a license?
NICK MONTFORT: Yes.
So generally, all the
code is ISC licensed.
So it's all free software.
When you find it online,
it has this license.
I have a note in "#!" saying
that it's free software
and where to find it online.
But we didn't repeat
the license for each one
of these very short programs,
many of which-- I mean,
we have a 32-character
Perl program.
It's a little onerous to include
even a very short license
in that case.
It's also a question as to
whether a 32-character Perl
program can be copywritten.
I'm not sure-- short phrases do
not fall under copyright law.
So it's not obvious
to me whether those
would be afforded
copyright protection.
AUDIENCE: Well
then, then followup
question is, does your
code contain expression.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, I
hope-- well, I hope not.
Yes.
Because most of it is a
very conceptual project.
I mean, certainly,
"Taroko Gorge"
is expressive of a type of
experience, a type of feeling.
It's one that can
be continued, that
doesn't have a particular end.
It's an experience of nature.
So there are aspects
of expression in it.
But to me, that's not the point.
It is something that
I'm using to investigate
language, form, poetry.
And other people
can do other types
of projects that are more
focused on expression.
But those are the things that
interest me particularly, is
really to be an investigator
of language, which
has such an amazing history
and such a rich potential
to connect and divide
in various ways.
AUDIENCE: What about color?
Have you ever played with
terminal colors, like 256 color
xterm, for example?
NICK MONTFORT: I
think, probably,
just decorating things on the
web is about the only thing
that I've done
along those lines.
With things like Concrete Perl,
which are visual programs,
I really tried to
make them more or less
generic to the color of
text or the typography.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
NICK MONTFORT: All right.
AUDIENCE: So the
generators you've presented
are all fairly minimal.
So you have any
longer form works
that aren't quite
interactive fiction,
but are somewhere between
these minimalistic examples
and normal Z-machine programs?
NICK MONTFORT: Yeah.
So certainly, the focus in
"#!" is on these very short
programs.
I think that almost all of
them fit on a single page.
And some of them
are much shorter.
And it's probably-- yeah,
so "Through the Park"
and "Taroko Gorge"
go across two pages.
They're quite brief.
In part, my interest
in these short programs
is just that there's
still enough to do
in the very short
amount of space--
a very small amount of
computation-- that's
interesting that I don't
feel like moving on
from that in many cases.
It's also something where I can
afford to more intensively go
over this and understand
more about it if I
have something short.
I have systems--
I mean, "Megawatt"
is 350 lines, which is
getting to be longer.
It's not a large scale,
enterprise program.
I do have this
system, Curveship,
which is a full
interactive fiction system.
And it's implemented in Python.
And it does the
basics of what systems
like Inform, TADS, that
line of work will implement.
And plus, it also allows
for narrative variation
so that the same
underlying events
can be represented
different ways.
So that's a larger scale
project which I'm pleased with.
But on the other hand,
I've never really written--
I have demonstration programs
that I've done in Curveship.
But I've never really
written an original work,
in Curveship, that was an
extensive original work.
And I think it's
possible that that's
because I spent so much time
working on the system itself
and building all of this out.
So my focus has been
on this smaller scale.
But I think there's
interesting possibilities
for individual and
collaborative authorship
of medium scale works.
I mean, one of these
pieces that is definitely
larger-- which is a
collaboration of mine,
with Stephanie Strickland--
is "Sea and Spar Between."
So this is a poetry generator
we published in 2011.
And it's a conflation of a Emily
Dickinson's-- a lexicon of her
poems and of the
lexicon of "Moby Dick."
And it's about 225
trillion stanzas
that are arranged
in this lattice.
So there's coordinates,
and you can go to them.
It's actually a fixed
text that you can go to.
But it's so large that
it's meaningless to treat
it that way.
You might as well just open
it up, and look around,
and encounter it the
way we're doing now.
And this is a larger
scale project--
I'd say sort of medium scale.
And for a collaborative
project that spanned some time,
it was pretty useful to
do something of this size.
So you can go to-- if I
go to 0.500, what's that?
"Listen now, for
hueless is the sky.
One air, one air,
one each, one play.
Paradise!
Spirit!"
And then, I can
go somewhere else.
I'm just navigating here.
If I go back to 1.500-- oh,
0.500 is what I was looking
for.
Oops.
I have to type it right-- I
should get the same thing.
Yeah.
"Listen now, for
hueless is the sky."
So this is an example of
a medium scale project.
I mean, there's different
things that come out.
So this has actually
been remixed the way
that "Taroko Gorge" was
once, that we know of.
It's been translated
to Polish, which
is an amazing undertaking.
And it's also been remixed
to create a piece called
"House of Leaves
of Grass," which
is based on Mark Danielewski
and Walt Whitman.
And Mark Sample did that.
So one of the things is that,
these very small scale pieces,
they invite others to
study and understand them,
to manipulate them,
to rework them
to create their own
pieces based on them.
So in that case, "Taroko
Gorge" was, I think,
extremely successful.
If I'd made it 10 times the size
that it was-- it fit on one--
it's less than 66 lines long.
It fits on one dot
matrix printed page.
And if I'd made it
10 times as big,
nothing that you saw there,
along the right-hand side--
all of those remixes and
work-- would have happened.
So there's some
significant benefits
to doing smaller pieces.
And I think that you shouldn't
exceed the size of your concept
in writing programs like
this, poems like this,
in this sort of code.
But if you have something
that is a bit more expensive,
then it makes sense to
have a larger project.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
NICK MONTFORT: If
There's no questions,
I'll just offer
some company names
for anyone who would like them.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
let's thank Nick.
NICK MONTFORT: All right.
Thanks.
Thank you.